we'll go outta time
it's finally here infinity war is in
theaters that we get to see all of our
favorite Marvel superheroes back on
screen but this begs the question who's
the best of engine alright so now we
have six Marvel super fans who are here
to argue their case for their favorite
Marvel Avengers I'm destiny and I'm here
to fight for the Black Panther
well kondeh forever blip-blip blip-blip
I'm Chris I'm representing spider-man
I'm Evan and I'm fighting for Captain
America I've got at the lower Bay I'm
here to represent Doctor Strange because
he has cool hand side I'm Brendan I'm
here to rep Iron Man because he's not
just a superhero he's also a billionaire
playboy philanthropist
hi I'm Michelle thing I'm here for team
Thor first ops spider ways because we
have to establish the rules first here
people who cannot talk unless you have
the hammer in your hand let's do this
thank you first of all Black Panthers
great to love Black Panther my argument
for Tony Stark for Ironman is that there
are no Avengers without his own stuff
Thor or even a black panther where some
of his abilities are obviously like
mystically infused he's a lot more
fragile his Tony Stark is just a dude
and look what he's been able to
accomplish he can make the people around
him better you can have ten random
people in a room and Tony Stark can make
them ten superheroes any other avenger
can't really do that yeah for the
culture the reason why Black Panther
T'Challa
came to Charlotte as you will address
him is the best avenger is because where
did infinity war take place Wakanda he
has my brainy oh there is no saving the
world without vibranium Iron Man is very
selfish what what and that makes a great
leader where do you cut the new shield
from okay so the shield's vibranium you
said earlier that oh you can't save the
world up without vibranium I saw
infinity war did vibranium save the
world I don't think it yeah the reason
why Thor is the best Avenger is not only
does he have the most incredible power
he is a great person you started off he
was selfish he was banished because he
was so self-centered over the course of
the MCU you see him really developing
humanity and fighting not only for
people on Asgard but also the people of
Earth good person points for our
Avengers it goes a long way people fight
a man has to be one of those courageous
Avengers homeboys 16 years old I was 18
17 that's not magic but you have the
power of the hammer how old he is he's
always rushing into the fight he's
always out there to help in infinity war
what jumps on that spaceship goes with
that spaceship he also becomes the irons
basically makes the plan to kill one of
the Black Order he's doing way more than
I was a teenager that's not saying
what's okay
he's the best Avenger because he has the
most approved and he proves it every
single step of the way Captain America
is technically the First Avenger he was
the first one to ban everyone together
also he's the only one who can actually
hold Thor's hammer because he is all
pure he's a little kid who got some
power and now he uses it to make the
world a better place
first of all Captain America betrayed
the Avengers just because forgive my
friend come back okay and where was
Captain America in the beginning movie
you know where was he he was licking
cookies at all thoughts of strange got
to do is he kept America we're gonna
teleport so Uranus and leave him there
he has magic he could multiply Captain
America wouldn't know what to do it I
can strange wouldn't have his powers for
the word for Captain America Doctor
Strange got his own power one through
the monks they had none to do but
Captain America but he won't be part of
the Avengers he don't need to be part of
the magic who is the best of energy but
he could be his own adventure has he
been included yet is he actually an
adventure yet not yet I know yay
but in the comics he is your talk about
comics I move very very strong and
passion arguments with you two you're
gonna have way too much time are very
disappointing so I guess we need to
check with our judges judges final
answer so I think after I concur with
the judges
you we should get one sentence to say
why your character is the best Avenger
am I ever
sitala is a plan of the people for the
people which creates quality leadership
Tony Stark is a mortal man without
superpowers could die at any point that
bravery that courage is what makes him
truly special invested in Captain
America is the First Avenger and he is a
captain he's the only person suited to
actually lead the Avengers Thor has
literally lost everything his parents
his siblings his entire planet when he
pulls everything together he was the
best Avenger he's not an Avenger yet
real time real time black panther it
gets his own category for sure okay
the worst so if we're gonna be doing it
under the guise of who's the best
Avenger okay then for that based off of
the facts that were stated in the
debates
[Music]
within my body I'm not allowed to say
that Black Panther is not the winner I'm
going to say is but Captain America is
the best Avenger Black Panther is the
best Marvel superhero and that's where
we're gonna leave it
[Music]
you